homes should one get stuck mine eyes
Elementary Watson elementary what do you
see everything
that because Sherlock Holmes too
directed by Guy Ritchie stars Robert
Downey jr. Jude Law
Nomi rapist Jared Harris and Rachel
McAdams now I pride myself on not
spoiling plots or really anything in my
reviews and I'm gonna do my best to do
that here I'm just gonna sum up the plot
quickly because I don't want to really
get too much into it because if you're
interested in seeing the film already
you're going to see it if and if you're
not interested you're gonna look at the
pie yourself I don't do it for you but
if you don't wanna get spoiled that's
great and I'm not going to do it for you
Sherlock Holmes is going up against this
guy who has an extremely evil plot that
has to do with starting a war and he's
trying to avert that obviously in his
very special Sherlock Holmes way and
that leads him on a great mystery filled
with action mystery and suspense oh how
I've missed you Holmes have you I bet he
nursery strips yeah I really enjoyed the
first film I had a lot of fun with the
first movie I liked the directorial
style and that's really the thing I
think kind of hanges on whether or not
you will like that film and especially
the second one because Guy Ritchie style
takes a little bit of getting used to
and it's definitely different and it has
a very visceral feel to it very
in-your-face loud a different style than
normal and for me that's very
commendable because I love seeing
something that's different than the
average norm what are we up against here
the most formidable criminal mind in
Europe
professor James Moriarty I love Sherlock
Holmes - I actually liked him more in
the first film I've liked a lot of films
lately and to be honest a lot of people
have given me hate saying you're getting
too easy on movie or something but I've
never once given a false opinion on a
film if I feel a certain way that's how
I'm going to tell you and I love this
movie I was really surprised how much
fun I had of this movie if you liked the
first film if you liked the style the
first phone then this is going to be
just a great fun time for you more than
likely it's one of the funnest times
I've had of the movies all year if we
can stop him should prevent the collapse
of Western civilization new pressure
Robert Downey jr. I think is one of the
greatest actors we have working today
and Jude Law is magnificent in this
movie and both of them work so well
together the chemistry in the first film
was really good but it's even better
here there's much more of a kind of
bromance going on really like yes there
they're a team and you can really feel
their relationship there's a great
emotional way to their relationship and
I really dug that aspect of the film
also the action in this movie is very
very well done an extremely well
choreographed and filmed well you too
concerned citizens
mr. Holmes I feeling you're in danger
there's a particular set piece near the
latter half of the film involving a
forest chase that actually blew my mind
and is probably the best action scene
I've seen in theaters all year having
seen Mission Impossible 4 yet I mean my
mouth was hanging open a little bit I
was very impressed the villain was very
strong too he was extremely evil and you
really could feel that undercurrent
especially whenever him and Sherlock
Holmes would clash whether physically or
through dialogue extremely riveting
dialogue in this movie hilarious this is
much funnier than the first film which
was also funny but I am seriously from
seeing to seem consistent laughs really
good movie extremely surprised are you
sure you want to play this game I'm
afraid your goose
oh dear
great great production design beautiful
costumes great set pieces lots of fun if
you want a fun time with the movies this
winter Sherlock Holmes to check it out
I'm going to give Sherlock Holmes to an
a very surprised just
make it round
that's a that comes so let me know down
it's stuck when squared did you like the
first Sherlock Holmes film or what's
your favorite Guy Ritchie film let me
know I would like to know your thoughts
if you like this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck my
eyes